what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are gonna watch the
latest easter eggs and breakdown from
new rock stars of marvel's what if but
speaking of marvel we actually have a
special box here from funko gaming so
we're going to do a special little funko
unboxing so we're going to open this up
and see what's in store here
all right john i'm going to pull
something out from okay i'm going to
pull something out and then
tell me what it is it feels big
it's a big thing this is apparently
marvel battle world what's more what is
that a collectible adventure game
storage case
let's google it battle world is a
revolutionary cooperative expandable
collectible adventure game featuring
dozens of characters from all over the
marvel universe oh okay i see i'm
keeping oh so there's all this stuff in
here to support the game
i assume okay so we got here we got a
groot
that's right i i'm groot no i'm bane oh
you got black panther perfectly suited
for today
captain marvel
everyone's favorite what is this oh
battle ball oh how cool that must be
important can we open it
some cards oh awesome there's a plenty
of good stuff in here yeah there we go
another one i didn't even notice here
what is this the collector's tower oh
the collector's right there yeah
not batteries don't notice it thank you
so much
wait to learn how to play i can't wait
to play with john get extremely
competitive put him down and apologize
lately oh it'll buy i already accept
oh yeah that makes okay with the special
url we should have known it was marvel
purchaser battleball
funko.com marvel battle world today
people thank you so much said marvel and
that's all we needed link in description
check them out
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 2 which explores what
would happen if t'challa became
star-lord spared us all from thanos and
left us with the collector cosplaying as
hella
those antlers don't belong to you you
don't deserve it set in my favorite
corner of the mcu the cosmic toy box of
the guardians of the galaxy this episode
is filled with easter eggs and subtle
details so let's break this down frame
by frame for everything you missed we
open on morag coordinates m31b j044
37.99 plus 4129 i know that means the
same as those in james gunn's 2014 film
coordinates that gun has hinted point
toward his infamous long-lost hidden
easter egg that he confirmed we had new
rockstars got a big piece of the watcher
ponders what was it
just tell us the piece by the nature of
your world getting at the deeper theme
of nature versus nurture in this episode
both guardians films explore the idea of
family and whether peter quill is
forever cursed by his biological lineage
or capable of redefining himself with a
family of his own choosing that's what i
want from marvel's what if generally
speaking why i love this episode is
because of that theme of nature versus
nurture how one switch instead of
picking up peter quill they pick up
t'challa and everything in the universe
changes having the theme of nature
versus nurture like this is a much more
focused on that element i kind of feel
like that that would make such a big joy
out of just
what if generally speaking if that's
kind of how the events play out and i
mean you see it in this episode play in
multiple directions even with the
relationship to yondu and the rest of
the ravagers like that nurture affects
them totally as much as it does to
challenge
100 this episode ends up making a
compelling case for nurture with
formerly scarred characters like yondu
thanos nebula and drax all positively
benefiting from the experience of the
fresh altruism of t'challa in their
lives and t'challa's formerly royal
attitude of non-interference now
reshaped by his life as an explorer with
all of them and this episode ends with a
dark cautionary tale favoring nurture
with the fear of what would have
happened had peter quill not been
nurtured by his chosen family you see a
lot of people talk about how but it kind
of puts peter quill down doesn't it that
he wasn't a very good star-lord but the
thing is is that maybe right away or
earlier on t'challa makes for a better
star-lord and for an impactful star-lord
but i think having that ending moment
there maybe at any moment will play into
some episodes down the road i don't know
but that does show that no yes the
journey for peter quill to become a good
star-lord feels longer however it's the
necessary one
in order to have the universe be at
peace yeah for now now there's all the
nexus events and king and all that yeah
but you know what i mean you know where
i'm going with this this opening scene
has a few contrasts between t'challa's
approach and quills t'challa doesn't
have an awesome mixed playlist to dance
to and quill put the gravity trap on the
floor whereas t'challa holds it in his
hand and later reboxes it as a weapon
and of course there's korat's reaction
i'm just a junker man i was just just
checking stuff out hey you know what
there's another name you might know me
by star-lord who star-lord man legendary
outlaw versus i'm just an ordinary
junker but there is one name you may
know me by starlord i'm a huge fan of
your work now chadwick boseman voices
here one of four episodes this season
that he recorded voices for before he
passed away a year ago this month
and he's having a lot of goofy fun in
the role he says should we be bowing i
feel like we should be bowing i mean
unless we should be kneeling neither is
necessary please similar to bruce
banner's reaction to meeting t'challa in
infinity war should we bow
yeah he's a kid
that did not come to me in the moment do
not we don't do that here michael rooker
returns to voice yondu whose animated
form has fewer random straps and his
jacket is a brighter ravager red than
the darker tone of his live-action
wardrobe showing off how he's not as too
cool as he was before less of an
overlord of his crew and more of one of
the guys t'challa said if we still made
like the old days you'd only have half
of your teeth yeah in the film yondu had
a mouth full of golden teeth but here
you can see all of his teeth are still
mostly in place oh
what yeah what a what a neat detail that
is this is funny because like i've
always noticed those fake old teeth they
put them in because they're such a part
of that toothy grin but yeah he's just
got pearly white
that is a detail we missed for sure yeah
oh i really like that one oh dude see
t'challa should have been star-lord got
him brushing his teeth yondu would have
had better teeth nutella continues
besides wouldn't you rather use it to
jump start the colorian's dying star
save their system from extinction
colonians that's a deep cut to the rom
comics of the 80s where colonians were a
race of cat-like beings t'challa wants
to save them because he comes from a
panther or
that means the most to me copper wake up
copper this is free copper this detail
is for you copper taking a photo of the
cat this is what we have over here in
the corner
everyone loves a good cat cam here
charlo would have saved you and all your
people all the people from rob
rob rom-com
from the rom-coms
now instead of the milano t'challa named
his ship the mandela my favorite detail
from this episode when t'challa was
abducted in the year 1988 nelson mandela
was still a political prisoner mandela's
south african dialect of hosie was what
the spoken language of wakandan was
based on for the film and mentality
right
in the mcu echoing through the cosmos in
the local finale we have fought for the
right to experience yes now 20 years old
that's awesome
his father tachaka with john connie
returning to voice the role in the
wakandan throne room numerous
traditional tribal garb over his black
panther suit both of them are dressed as
they were in a very brief flashback in
black panther interesting detail here as
to chaka first walks up there are two
thrones side by side perhaps for t'chaka
and queen ramonda or for father and son
but later in the wide angle it's back to
just the one throne maybe an oversight
or a sign of t'challa's abdication by
leaving earth behind
that's an oversight they moved really
quick
get this thrown out of here ungrateful
spoiled brat i think they made a mistake
definitely a mistake that they made i
think in animation that have less
continuity problems oh yeah
because like everything is so vigorously
mapped but i would like the idea of both
thrones being there because you know in
civil war t'chaka dies and then when its
child returns home i love i love the
feeling that it provides of oh t'challa
gets to live as an adult with a side by
side with his father you know there are
two thrills that would be pretty cool
bye queen
kingdom here just two kings
that's all you need
totally disregard angela
the watcher's voiceover says what you
call destiny is just an equation
a product of variables yeah interesting
choice of words when you consider the
recent what if promo displayed uwatu's
pitch using the interface of the tva
follow me
enter the multiverse
of infinite possibilities
[Music]
remains creator of the tva in that loki
finale he had a series of non-linear
integration equations on his chalkboard
yeah just know these two are speaking a
very similar language and i will remind
you that in our season preview i
predicted a post-credits scene in which
he remains hosts the watcher in his
citadel chamber moments before loki and
sylvia arrive though wakandan border
wall has as it does in the films a
hexagonal grid structure which matches
the unt and navigation grid of the
universe seen in the guardian's films
captain marvel and endgame later this
episode we will learn that the wakandans
were actually experienced in space
travel meaning some of their tech might
have been extraterrestrial influence
that is something i did not consider at
all i know
space travel wakanda there's able to do
space travel extraterrestrial imbued
within the wakandan technology oh yeah
and they take all the credits yeah we
hear what kind of technology but they
got it from outsiders it's just the
story of the human race all over not
cool wakanda's wakandans stealing aliens
not cool but yeah and also to the other
point though too i feel like we will get
some specific tie-in to he who remains
or kang they're going to be they're
going to sometimes very overt about it
uh so that way this feels even more
essential to the experience of the
marvel cinematic universe kraglin is
voiced by sean gunn again and taser vase
a mutineer in volume 2 voiced again by
chris sullivan explain i don't know all
humans look alike to me the cosmic
readings where he was took nearly broke
our dial if there was anything not from
that planet on that planet it's there
referring to the meteorite and the
prologue of black panther that's now the
minds of mount bashanga but then back in
the present 20 years later the crew
hangs out on contrexia that's a
snow-covered planet that we saw in
guardians volume 2 but whereas those
ravagers hung out in the scummy street
level these guys kick it in the classy
nightclub still throughout the
background you can see the yellow sex
spots hanging about they relive their
war stories what about the central bank
heist don x4
[Applause]
mcu it might in the live-action things
be under cree occupation since the
squirrels were refugees in captain
marvel we might visit this place in the
marvel film korath says oh how about
when you own the anchor and resistance
yeah in the marvel comics ankara is the
homeworld of the slig it's from a 1979
fantastic four comic and then this
reveal how exactly did you stop thanos
the mad titan from decimating
oh no i'm a big enough man to admit when
i'm wrong josh brolin returns as thanos
having moved on from being a malthusian
eco-terrorist thanks to t'challa shown
in the light now t'challa having grown
up in a bubble and tarnished my
instead in a peaceful state of tribes
who settle their differences at warrior
falls and share their resources with
each other might have been that x factor
to break through to thanos sociopathy
and yeah 20 years after 1988 would be
2008 right as tony stark started to
become iron man and four years before
thanos would have sent loki to attack
earth so this thanos hasn't even gotten
close to his conquest of earth i would
have loved if in avengers infinity war
after they go into hip-hop what and then
thanos shows up and he's like let me
have a conversation
i believe we could solve this with an
argument yeah yeah we can talk ourselves
let's debate this
gentleman's debate but no i get it it's
it's the point in time when you're
having this conversation with thanos i
understand the bartender meanwhile is
drax you saved my home world from a cree
invasion let us take a picture to send
to my wife and daughter not voiced by
dave batista though the producers of the
show said that they tried to get in
touch with him but yeah drax is
referring to his wife yvette and their
daughter kamaria the kylosians killed by
ronen on thanos orders but now another
planet saved by t'challa in this world
what's going on with disney and the
communication all right scarlett
johansson trying to reach disney to
renegotiate marvel trying to reach dave
bautista to get him in here dave
bautista saying he wasn't contacted
what's going on second thing if i did
not know that was dave bautista i would
have thought it was day by day that was
a really good voice
and yet benicio the torah returns to
play the collector and i did not and he
doesn't even need to like
so weird
i was like i'm certain it's not i'm like
i'm pretty sure that's a different guy
nebula appears karen gillan returning to
voice her now unscarred with hardly any
cybernetic implants since thanos must
have spent fewer years torturing her
they might not have tortured her at all
t'challa tells her no he gardens now you
should talk to me and he really has
changed referring to thanos retirement
as a farmer on the garden in infinity
war and end game nebula tells him about
a heist she's planning do i have a job
for you
they're called the embers of genesis
yeah the music is the same jazzy heist
music used in the ant-man films
which is a heist movie
okay
nutrient-rich cosmic dust from an
ancient supernova with the power to
terraform entire ecosystems with one
ounce you can heal a dying planet in
minutes yeah the embers of genesis
aren't specifically in the marvel comics
but they do seem like the same kind of
cosmic particles that the eternals might
have used on ancient earth to enrich the
soil for agriculture and yeah this is
the kind of reallocation of resources to
stave off hunger that thanos was
referring to he had nebula butt heads
here i thought you work alone daughter
you mean she's your offspring adopted
yeah a callback to one of my favorite mc
running jokes between thor and loki and
he's my brother he killed 80 people in
two days
he's adopted i've never met this man in
my life he's my brother adopted and then
this is absence the collector tantalia
travon seen in guardians of the galaxy
and in infinity war has emerged instead
as the feared tyrant of the galaxy which
doesn't make sense because the collector
for a few minutes in mcu history had
both the power stone in his possession
while the reality stone was hidden
elsewhere in his vault and he knew what
both of those were he was very close to
being a rival of the thanos i'm very
curious to know from you guys do you
prefer the take that they did at the
collector and what if i mean i know that
some people might not be fully on board
with some of the humor that he provides
to the character but personally i would
be way more gravitated towards the live
action collector if they implemented
more of what they throw in here there is
a bit of a flamboyant gregarious
personality towards benissa latorre's
live-action portrayal it's a little bit
more subdued he's not threatened he's
not as threatening and he's not a
kingpin the way he is here and i kind of
would really like to see that version of
the collector in live action there's
there's a lot about the animated one i
prefer so i was curious to know what you
guys would say t'challa and yondu argue
in the eclector this is the massive
ravager ship that yondu escaped and
destroyed in guardians volume 2. yondu
says we steal from the rich and give to
the poor just like that earthling folk
hero of yours right robin leech robin
hood
robin leach marveled over excessive
wealth and lifestyle of the rich and
famous love that joke nebula says the
collector's got a famous kink for exotic
flora and fauna yeah reminding us of
when the collector weirdly offered to
buy groot's corpse now benicio del toro
said in an interview that tyvon sees
himself as a noah figure his collection
an arc to rebuild after some galaxy-wide
destruction and groot as a messed up
noah could be made
order running security so we see brock's
midnight corvus glaive ebony ma and call
obsidian all returning from infinity war
and in game but karina greets them
voiced again by affiliate level
oh my dearest nebula aren't you aside
for sore
i forgive me i couldn't help myself oh
and yes vanessa del toro has returned
here to voice security doesn't sound
like elections appears to be a giant
rhinoceros looking about as animated as
it did in the live-action film he now
wears this elaborate chest plate that
looks as guardian in nature or at least
something designed by e tree it has
these interesting engravings not too
dissimilar from bandraw's chest plate or
maybe a version of the asgardian
destroyer in the vault there is wow
from the post-credits scene thor of the
dark world which at first seemed like it
was gonna be adam warlock's cocoon until
james gunn changed it to have a new
golden cocoon in the guardians vol 2
post-credits scene and then retconned
that first one as an ancient version of
the sovereign cocoons is freaking adam
warlock gonna come into the mcu or not
no
it's not
mad i don't think we've been teasing it
for so long and i feel like the
conversation is just dropped on him you
know that's going to be the big surprise
of guardians 3. maybe they won't even
hype it or or allude to it but then at
the very end of the movie it'll finally
show up it's like even he puts him in
the post-credits scene of guardians too
one of the many post-credits scenes and
then james was like no i don't actually
have plans to use him like what the hell
stopped he's part of the marvel thing
you're supposed to tease a new thing
they pass cosmo the space dog who
growled at rocket in guardians volume
one but here he wags his tail at
t'challa another contains a dark elf and
then of course howard the duck with seth
green returning as the voice he directs
t'challa to the embers of genesis cosmic
flora down the hall take a louie at the
frost giants the hard ralph at the
cronins you're gonna see a sign for
elvish literature ignore that total
snooze
yeah i love that scared quack at the end
there but yeah he mentioned the frost
giants those are loki's people cronins
those are korg's people and elvish
literature maybe a joke about the long
dramatic elvish dialogue we all had to
sit through and throw the dark world
howard says you know what they say when
you're out of luck always go duck i'm
pretty sure no one says that oh they say
it really totally
little crack at the end there it was a
little rewording of his line in
guardians vol 2. you know what they say
you're out of luck until you've gone
done
howard stops for a drink at this bar
that looks a lot like the mos eisley
cantina bar from star wars so the
bartender is the robot that kind of
looked like a celestial that was in the
cicar bar serving valkyrie drinks it
looks so exactly that much just like
that set up and t'challa runs into this
garage which is filled with spaceships
that we've seen before front and center
is a commodore that's a pleasure craft
of the grand master endowed gas from
thor ragnarok that's actually tavon's
brother because they're both elders of
the universe now to the right of that is
another ship from the grand masters
garage that's a green painted cube that
take away easily joke that he designed
with an intentionally dumb shape and
then to the right of that closest to us
the quantum realm vessel of hank pym oh
wow
no it doesn't really make sense for
devon to have this because it didn't it
doesn't matter it looks like an
then further on on the left is a yellow
star blaster and that's a fighter
piloted by the nova corps fleet and
below that is a green ship with folded
wings that looks like another ship from
the grand master's garage
the star cluster is the necrocraft
piloted by roman sikarian soldiers and
guardians
and then another one of these was
hijacked by nebula to kamikaze into
thanos on titan and infinity war now on
the far left looks like it could be the
milano though the wing engines are
completely different and then just
behind the star blaster looks like it
could be an x-wing from star wars but
the s
it's got to be at least like a slight
allusion to it oh it totally looks like
it could be an x-ray
holy moly dude let's get some crossovers
how do you just commit some of these
like
ship's memory like the one you pointed
out that was way in the background of
thor ragnarok from the grand master i'm
like how did you see the ship and what
if that looks like the shot from that
one shot
it's like i'm so puzzled man every night
eric goes home to a white room with
padded walls where he just reads a tome
of marvel references ships faces places
and people do you just get lucky of
screenshotting the ship and then
dropping it into google image to find
visually similar images what what is the
mythology here man then t'challa's
necklace lights up when he finds a
wakandan spacecraft
yeah that was the sound of the talking
drum that was part of composer ludwig
joranson's score for black panther and
again proof that what condoms were
involved in space exploration which is
crazy now the interior of this craft is
covered in wakandan lettering which i
took the time of course
a few words you understand wasn't and
then you insane then in the comments as
we face the cockpit it looks like
positive and then on the right side and
negative across the top and then down
the sides simplify and and then on the
other side make shapes i don't know what
this is
thank you
so i want to say this thank you that
takes a lot of work eric make shapes and
it seems like all that time you took
really paid off
it did we got some word salad for the
mcu
thank you seriously i love the idea that
you're spending all this time
on to something
and you're like doesn't make sense it's
gibberish
that's first shot of all the words it's
just like oh man i wish that could be
the thumbnail
but t'challa finds these mannequins
wearing dora melange garb meaning the
collector must have killed these
soldiers and now has their wardrobe on
display and he sees his baba's mask
was abducted from earth by an alien
spacecraft if music there might sound
familiar that's the mournful ancestral
plane track from the black panther score
ebony mob binds t'challa by using the
broken glass similar to how he
repurposed broken material in his fight
against doctor strange and the others in
infinity war siobhan uses a cronin arm
against t'challa that's quite a wallop
does it not i hacked it off the carcass
of a terribly chatty troll
terribly jenny cronin this guy cut off
korg's arm now during this fight i like
how the talking drum picks up pace just
like it did to build up tension during
t'challa's warrior falls duel in black
panther
javon's weapons include captain
america's shield which in 2008 would
have been frozen in polar ice as well as
their gears
and then of course the headpiece of
hella whom tavon emulates with his
gesture oh
that woman had taste a necrosaur
courtesy of the asgardian goddess of
death
no clue how he would have gotten this or
any of this stuff because hella is a
freaking goddess of death i don't see
how he could have taken it from her
meanwhile as thanos in the other spite
in security you can hear a bowling pin
sound effect as he knocks him over
i thought i did
suck the matrix reloaded
the guardians of the galaxy music plays
yondu
sweet now it's a party t'challa and
yondu used the sticky fingers trick on
tavon to steal his gauntlet control the
same maneuver tony stark used on thanos
to steal back
in game and then on the reveal we hear
this great music
[Music]
this is more music from the black
panther score
and one of the prisoners closing in on
tivonne is a pluvian the same race as
martin x from stakar oguard's crew from
guardians of the galaxy
as they leave nowhere the embers of
genesis that kill the black order cause
life to spring from that skull making me
wonder if it could reanimate in some
form they return to wakanda and reunite
with the family
wearing the same white robes and
headpiece that she wore when she greeted
t'challa on his return in black panther
and they all dine okoye in thanos talk
my friend that sounds an awful lot like
genocide no no no because it's random
then i might add
efficiency
talks with shuri meanwhile craiglin says
jump points are the best they make your
face all scrambly they're a lot of fun
referring to their light speech on
sequence in guardians volume 2. the
final scene takes us to that dairy queen
in missouri the same one from guardians
vol 2. but here adult peter quill
listens to space age love song by a
flock of seagulls could be from james
gunn's awesome mix volume 3 since
volumes 1 and 2 mostly stuck to 70s
music ego says smart peter can't spare a
little time for dear old death and his
ship is parked out front all while the
watcher says too bad this might spell
the end of the world bringing us back to
that nature versus nurture debate of
this episode further prove that nurture
is so so important because for the
watcher to consider this apocalyptic
means that peter needed his experiences
with the ravagers and the guardians he
needed to meet them first in order to
know how wrong his biological dead ego
was and be able to fight back against
him and the closing title card pays
tribute to the late chadwick boseman the
hero this episode thankfully gave us
another adventure with support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at
nerocstarsmerch.com and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
another brilliant breakdown man wow i
knew that one would be a juicy one and i
knew that won't be a juice you go into a
collector episode you're like
or if there's an environment full of
people you know you know it's gonna be a
juicy new rockstars one guys subscribe
to them if you haven't done so already
eric voss off screen off filming by the
way is also an insanely nice humble
human being please just go show your
support to them we got our shirts from
new rockstars merch that we're rocking
right now subscribe click that bell hit
that like button of course thank you to
funko battle world we remembered it's
funko battle world thanks for sponsoring
this video see you guys soon
you